Transcriber: rana heloun
المدقّق: gaith Takrity
هل تعرفون أن الأهوار قد تكونت
منذ عشرة ألاف سنة
على مدى مساحة تزيد على
ستة آلاف كيلو متر مربع
في جنوب السهل الرسوبي من العراق.
ومنذ ذلك الحين حتى اليوم
لا زالت الأهوار باقية
رغم النكسات والنكبات والتعذيب والجفاف
والسياسات القمعية.
هذه الأهوار يسكنها عرب الأهوار
ونسميهم أحيانا المعدان.
وهم يسكنون في الايشين، تلك الجزر الثابتة
التاريخية المرتفعة عن سطح الماء،
وكونّوا إضافة لها جزرًا خاصة بهم
وهي الجزر الطافية.
إنها تشغل مساحات هائلة
بين القصب السامق علوًا
حول القنوات المائية والبحيرات الواسعة
كبحيرة أم النعاج والبركة
البغدادية وأم الطيارة.
وهم سلالة أولئك السومريين والأكاديميين
الذين عاشوا في المدن الكبرى.
قبل خمسة آلاف سنة كانوا هنا في هذه
البقعة في منطقة الأهوار السومريين
الذين بنوا الحضارة الأولى في العالم
والمدن الأولى في العالم،
فكانت هنالك أور وأوروك وأريدو.
وهنا انطلق الحرف الأول
والقوس المعماري الأول والعجلة الأولى،
وبنوا واحدة من أجمل نظم الري في العالم.
لا زالت قائمة اليوم في مدينة الوركاء
وكذلك في مدينة أور.
ورغم محاربة الأهوار من الناحية السياسية
ابتداء من السنوات الساحقة
فقد جففها العباسيون يومًا ما
لقمع ثورة الزنج
وتوالت النكبات على الأهوار العراقية،
إلا أنّنا منذ عام 2003 أدركنا
أهمية الأهوار العراقية.
وشعرنا أنّه علينا أن نحافظ على هذه البيئة
لأنّنا سنحافظ طبعًا
على الاقتصاديات المُستدامة
ونحافظ أيضًا على المناخ
ونحافظ على اللغات المحكية
ونحافظ على أساطيرنا
وحكاياتنا منذ ذلك الحين.
لكن مثلما قلنا أن جفافا حدث
أو تجفيف حدث قبل أن يكون جفافًا
في تسعينات القرن الماضي،
وهذا الجفاف قد أثر كثيرًا على بيئة الأهوار
فقد هاجر أكثر من ثلاثين ألف نسمة
من الأهوار إلى أماكن قصية
وهذه الأماكن القصية بالحقيقة هي المبازل
في كل من بابل وكربلاء الكوت
وإلى آخره من المدن
استبيحت الثروة الحيوانية كاملة.
والأسماك قلت كثيرا وانخفضت إلى
أكثر من 95 بالمئة،
وأيضا في هذا المصاب أصبح هنالك حطام
أصبحت الأهوار حطاما،
وكان علينا أن نبتكر جزء من الحلول.
ما هي الحلول التي نبتكرها للأهوار العراقية
بعد أن جفت الأهوار العراقية
وفقدت الكثير من خصائصها
الاجتماعية والاقتصادية؟
أعتقد أن ثمة حلول وهذه الحلول ممكنة.
الحلول تتلخص بالآتي:
أولًا، إنشاء سد على شط البصرة
لكبح المياه التي تتدفق بدون فائدة هناك.
والناحية الأخرى إعادة النظر
في استراتيجية الزراعة
لأننا نهدر تقريبا من 70 إلى 85
متر مكعب من المياه.
وكذلك إعادة النظر
في طرق الإرواء التقليدية
لأن كفاءة الري في العراق اليوم
من 32 إلى 36 بالمئة فقط.
ومن ناحية أخرى علينا إعادة النظر
في المنظومة الهيدرولوجية
لأنّنا نخسر سنويًا بحدود 11 مليار
متر مكعب من المياه بالتبخر.
علينا أن نُخرِج على سبيل المثال بحيرة
الثرثار من نظام الري في العراق
لأن بحيرة الثرثار كانت ضمن نظام
ري اعتمدت وفرة المياه.
ابتداءً من عام 2015 كانون الأول
أصبحت المياه متوفرة بشكل قليل
وأصبح الطلب على المياه كثير.
علينا أيضا أن نُحَدِث خططنا
بما يسمى خطة السور
للمياه التي نديرها الآن.
من جانب آخر، ينبغي أن يكون هنالك تكامل
بين القطاعات الأساسية المستفيدة من المياه.
حقًا أن الأهوار العراقية
أصابها البؤس الكبير
وحلت بها مشاكل كبيرة.
لكن في قلب الأهواريين
مقولة همنغواي الشهيرة:
“قد يتحطم المرء ولكنه لن يهزم”.
لا يستطيع أحدا ما أن يهزم الأهواريين.
واليوم الأهواريين الذين غادروا هذا المكان
سيعودون يوما ما إليه مرة أخرى.
حقيقة الأهواريون يثقون
بمقولات مشهورة لديهم
أن الشمس تدور،
هو بالأحرى إنّ الأرض تدور
لكن لدى الأهوار ثقة أن الشمس تدور
والماء يثور والظلمة يسحقها النور.
ومع هذا نحتاج الكثير من العمل
لكي ننتقل اليوم من مرحلة بائسة.
وينتقل الأهواريون إلى سومر بلاد القصب
تلك المنطقة التي غادروها شتاتًا،
سيعودون إليها جميعا.
قبل أن نغادر القاعة أحب أن أقول
لكل عشاق الأهوار
يا عشاق الأهوار اتحدوا
فيد واحدة لا تصفق.
وشكرًا.